it is with great sadness that we hear of  the death of her majesty queen elizabeth  ii  who was much loved and admired across  the country and the wider commonwealth  for her grace and unfailing kindness  to those she met in the course of her  public duties  the queen's contribution to and  dedication in the service of the country  throughout her life  was and will continue to be an example  to us all  on behalf of the people of team bridge  district council  i would like to convey our deepest  sympathies to the royal family at this  sad time  as a mark of respect we will be flying  our flags at half-mast during this time  of mourning  and we will open a book of condolence  which will be available at old ford  house  and more information and support is  available on our website